[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
previously on model lifestyle the last
coffee I'm having with Daniel Daniels
favorite thing in the world is coffee I
thinks this is a special manager and I
miss you damn bro
thanks for teaching me the ways of life
and
[Music]
I'm happy you came to say goodbye
no it's not say goodbye this is too
emotional guys yeah the aptitude is good
time to go
[Music]
do you want some coffee
thanks guys hello good morning here from
South Africa I am home finally with my
amazing wife and our dog here Togo last
time when you guys saw him he looked a
little bit different you know yeah
Nikita shaved in me Ana Mohawk as well
but this is how it really looks like
when he's harris's yeah I thought it's a
good time to ask Nick it up to talk to
you guys because some of you asked
Daniel how does your wife feel if you do
international modeling how does it feel
being married the distance and then also
jealousy and those kind of stuff so
we've been married in case you did not
know for almost like is yes and I've
been doing modeling for over 12 so let
me say how do you feel being married to
international monitors the questions I'm
gonna make some tea
in the meantime okay well first off
we've met each other since 2007 so it's
been quite a while and in the beginning
when we started dating I also did a
little bit of planning myself so to be
honest yeah because Louis also part of
the industry I think I was able to
understand the situations and some of
the scenarios better but let's be real
in the beginning it was difficult it was
being away of difficult being away from
Daniel for three months at a time
so is
yeah that's not easy yeah it does we do
have our pleasure shout out to the girls
that we need to work through their
everyday life and things happening that
we need to sort out and get through and
in the beginning I'm gonna be honest I
was a bit jealous because you don't know
that person that well I mean you only
started dating now so you haven't really
gotten the chance to see how the person
is and reactances and situations how
they socialize and deal with other
people but I think the most important
aspects not just in our relationship but
in any relationship is that she needs to
have that respect you need to have that
trust trust yeah and you need to have
that honesty to be honest about who you
are really
and share that out of medicine yes a
trust is earned and so a lot of people
forget so when we met we didn't know
each other that well so we got to know
each other and over time I earned my
trust
Nikita earned her trust and yeah I have
to say with that on talking about that
he's never given me a reason to even
doubt him or to be jealous of him so
that was mainly because I think my own
few you know little insecurities that I
had in the beginning that's the reason
why I was a bit jealous this might be
sound a bit offensive
some of the viewers but when you are
jealous it's something that I noticed
and because of recent experience
sometimes it's not about that other
person or what they are doing so I see
you down with your teen yes let's go
have a seat
yeah that's good sit down comfortably
and talk about this okay so it was a
very loving dog yeah he's very special
to us I'm missing my log when I travel
but okay let's continue okay so I think
the biggest thing about being married to
the mountain model is missing one
another and trying to cope with everyday
life and responsibilities and stuff
sometimes I learn because that is super
hot especially currently I'm studying
for my degree in its action design so
it's going very hectic being 29 years
old and being a full-time student and
then not having my husband with me to
help me with some of the house chores or
going shopping things like that and then
of course missing each other and we've
got a very very very good relationship
we've got a very good marriage and I
think that is the most difficult is not
having my best friend with me
every day coming home just just being
with each other you know sharing the
thoughts on what happened before the day
and stuff like that yeah so how how how
was it for you traveling and be away
from that see that the thing is about
the traveling is it's fun
like I said in some other videos because
you have this amazing experience of
meeting different people different
cultures and you make new friends and
but you know the saying that there's no
no place like home and that's true and
for me homies where Nikita is so it
doesn't matter where we are as long as
we're together that feels like home and
so Nikita is here she's still here with
her family and she's got her friends
here she sometimes she travels with me
as well but for shorter periods of time
but for me I am abroad 2 to 3 months at
a time which is a long time and then I
miss my family and this Nikita I miss
the dog and this South Africa the food
all those kind of stuff you do miss it
so it is not easy but I do know what we
are working towards so we want to have
kids one day and we need the money right
so when I travel I am very focused and I
just think ok let's do this two to three
months let's do it let's get the money
because ultimately it is for her it is
for our kids it is for the future as
well
[Music]
it's exactly the same for me it's very
important to remember that because what
might happen is you might sit at home
and then you might think oh life is so
difficult and I'm going through such a
difficult time missing that person so
much you get so caught up in your own
little world and your own thoughts and
ideas that you don't you need to remind
yourself that it's exactly the same for
that for the other party for that other
person yeah if not even worse for them
because like I said earlier I'm here in
South Africa I've still got my friends
I've got my family we as Daniella
travels to another country where he
needs to learn about a new culture and
new people everything he does he doesn't
know the environment the transport so I
don't like that job and he doesn't have
anybody there to help him with that
he doesn't have anybody so to friends
family thing that's it's even harder for
him yeah but I want to mention one thing
that for us is very important I talked
about this in another video about how
the divorce rate is just increasing day
by day and from a Makita
I think the thing is that that I when I
look at her I
take your needs and I put it above my
own because as soon as I'm selfish in
this relationship
their relationship cannot work it is
impossible and sometimes you have this
fairytale idea of what a relationship
should be like but when you get really
into it it is hard work and it's all
about putting the other person above
yourself and it might sound strange but
if you do that you are more happy and it
can not be just a one way thing it needs
to be both ways and in that way there's
there's no place for selfishness in a
relationship yeah every every action
creates a reaction so if you think about
that other person's needs and put them
before yourself it automatically makes
that person feel loved and feel wanted
so in turn it makes that person put more
effort into you to know they want to do
more they want to show more love they
want to make you feel wants it yeah as
well and by saying this we don't mean
like being a pushover
like just let the other person do
whatever they want because you want to
put their needs above your own no we
mean that you discuss everything
communication is so important so so
whenever I mean Nikita we need to make
decisions we discuss it but I'm not
selfish and Nikita's not selfish and we
both work towards the best solution for
any kind of problem that we have what we
are talking about today in this video
basically boils down to one of the
biggest questions that people also ask
us the candid relationship survive
something like this can are you able to
be married and have this type of
lifestyle that we have
and yes you can because sure yo here we
are we've known each other for 11 years
almost been married for nine years he
only comes back for two maybe three
weeks when we need to that in South
Africa so yes we are proof and from
experience we can say that it does work
but you have to want it to work you have
to put in effort sorry dad doggies go on
take care of our dog here so it
basically just comes down to that you
wanted to make you have to want to make
an effort you have to want to make it
work because if you are not going to put
in hard work and still try and support
that each other with that type of
lifestyle it is going to be more
difficult yeah is there anything else
you think they would once a year well uh
one question that I have gotten a lot
from from other specifically other
ladies is when they see photos of Daniel
and women look at his videos and stuff
on YouTube that always ask me Wow Nikita
but I would be so jealous aren't you
jealous why are you okay with everything
and I think I personally just want to
answer that question for three hours as
a woman out there like I said before
Daniel does not give me a reason to
doubt him or to be jealous of that and
one thing that is very very important to
remember is that he married me he did
not marry any of the other girls that he
dated before or that he's worked with he
he chose me and to be his partner in
life
and I think just do that and I think
that's the most important thing to
remember if he did one someone else
thing to you I would not be his wife I
would not be sitting here so look at
yourself you know don't go and make
assumptions about situations for example
in the beginning
Daniel had to stay behind after fashion
shows to mingle with people to build
that relationship to build a little bit
of networking with with the people in
the industry so I would be home alone
and I know I've been the fashion show in
in at about 11:00 and he'd only be home
in around say 1 o'clock in the morning
so in that situation don't go and sit
and make assumptions of oh yo he's
probably with another girl
or he's probably doing bad so that that
is the worst thing that you could ever
do to yourself I think making those
assumptions are based on your
insecurities and it's nothing to do
about the guy or husband so I think it
depends on the relationship itself you
know people should not make generalize
the assumptions about this is how a
relationship is what this is how a
relationship is so let me tell you this
what I do is modeling and I'm a youtuber
that's not who I am I am Daniel I'm also
a son and also a brother I'm also a
hospital and so one day I always would
be a father
maybe a grandfather right and so you
have to look at these labels and just
push them out and look at the person so
these fashion shows and stuff if it's in
South Africa is far away to Johannesburg
I Drive for
I don't stay out too late but I keep her
updated and until hey this is what's
happening this is what I'm doing and
then she comes with me sometimes as well
so do not cut each other off from each
other's lives so our kind of lives is
like how do you say yeah because he's a
talker so I did the video now for the
male model walk and she was there so did
the videos for yeah but in the beginning
dianna begin here in the beginning we we
weren't oh I was not in the fashion
industry that much I was not a
photographer I was a business assistant
so I think what helped with that is that
Daniel made me a part of his world he
made an effort to share information with
me to share his experiences with me to
take me like with him
not physically sometimes but he
discussed this whole journey with me and
I was on on this journey with him you
know he made me a part of everything
that was very important so and I think
that's why I understood and tried to see
things from his perspective also because
how is it for him to deal with these
things he could have just as well turned
around and wins like okay so being a
model and being in the industry does not
like he said earlier and make him a
different person I was business
I also worked with a lot of other people
and a lot of other men so you can't
generalize something or a situation just
because that person is in the
entertainment industry whether they are
model actor a singer or whatever the
case may be because these situations can
happen in any type of business or
lifestyle or working environment that
that you have you know alright ya know
so it's about like I said in the
beginning of the video the most
important thing is trust if they give
you a reason by all means you know
don't stay in that relationship but if
they don't give you a reason to be
doubtful or jealous about of something
don't B's trust that person look at what
they do how they act how they are in
certain life in in certain situations
and with certain relationships of other
people yeah
just the last thing I might quickly
mention is that we are Christian as well
we are reborn question is not just a
traditional Christian where we say yeah
we're Christian and we live differently
for us the way our marriages build is is
build upon love and true love and we
have this kind of guidance and we know
how we should treat each other with that
love and that is probably the most
important thing that keeps our marriage
strong yeah maybe I'll share a little
bit more about that later on but not
really on this channel I'll make another
channel later on if you guys are very
curious than you can shake it out yeah
that is
thing I think it's because we have the
beliefs that we have it also helps lots
in our relationship we have confident
confidence in who we are as an
individual person yeah and also in each
other in each other I thought yeah all
right guys that's it a thing yeah if you
have any other questions my granule sake
please put them in the comment section
below and have an amazing day
cheers guys
[Music]